moment la ferme il a agi de plus que
jamais les médias autour d'une question
fondamentale sur le droit de blasphémer
mais aussi sur la portée et les
conséquences des contenus publiés en
ligne par les adolescents un débat
acharné autour de cette adolescente
menacé de mort pour avoir injurié dans
une série de vidéos en ligne
les religions et notamment l'islam
depuis plusieurs jours responsables
politiques internautes et éditorialistes
se dispute à couteaux tirés sur la
question une preuve que l'emballement
sur internet plus rapidement devenir
incontrôlables quand la machine à buzz
s'emballe et que les internautes se
déchaînent se souvient également de la
ferme enel cette candidate de the voice
dont certains internautes étaient allés
rechercher d'anciennes publication sur
twitter pour la faire tomber des tweets
complotistes autour des attentats qui
avaient fait grand bruit et avait
contraint tf1 à l'évincer de son
programme musical sur internet on peut
trouver une fonctionnalité méconnu mais
accessible à tous c'est le dark web
dessus on peut y acheter de la drogue
des armes ou encore missionné des tueurs
à gages
plus inquiétant encore les données
bancaires sont régulièrement piratés et
nos informations personnelles pourraient
être divulgués ce soir avec nous sur le
plateau de thé pmp ravin des bois un
hacker qui raconte dans son livre lève
toi et codes les coulisses d'internet et
de ses années le piratage le pire est à
venir avec selon lui à 11 septembre
numérique ou chaînes de télévision et à
et services publics pourrait se faire
pirater
alors selon vous doit-on avoir peur
d'internet alors ces derniers jours donc
on l'a vu un c vrai que l ai marqué
encore par tout ce qui se passe sur les
réseaux sociaux sur internet
et faut-il avoir peur d'internet déjà
rabbins des bois paraît que vous avez
dessiné il ya pas longtemps de pirater
l'école sciences po vous avez fait quoi
alors c'était l'année dernière en fait
ouais j'ai été candidat pour le concours
de sciences po paris
voilà j'ai réussi à trouver une faille
de sécurité sur leur site et j'ai voulu
les les avertir en fait de façon à
pouvoir régler ça et j'avais aucune
intention malveillante ou criminelles
quelles qu'elles soient et ils ont fini
par porter plainte en fait d'accord
portant plainte
bah moi samassa m'a très clairement
détruit ma vie et du coup j'ai décidé
d'écrire un livre de raconter mon
histoire
on peut gagner énormément d'argent avec
internet mais ça peut être également
très très dangereux voilà je pense que
c'est la révolution clairement de notre
alors vous êtes rentrés dans leur
système
alors est-ce qu'on peut rentrer dans des
scoop avant les adresses mail de
certains est-ce qu'on peut rentrer dans
les mails de certaines personnes ou pas
revient sur la pirater leur compte mail
c'est facile ça peut pirater des
adresses email on peut pirater des
serveurs des sites internet en fait à
partir du moment de se connecter à
internet c'est vulnérable même votre
monde connecté cyril qui vous indique je
sais pas vous
votre performance de 15 par exemple ça
ça peut être piraté d'accord alors vous
et vous restent anonymes forcément est
ce que on peut pirater aussi les réseaux
sociaux attention on peut on peut
pirater des comptes twitter facebook on
peut aussi faire des opérations de masse
en fait c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui les
réseaux sociaux sont utilisés de façon à
pouvoir l'utiliser de façon à pouvoir
mettre des idées dans votre tête en fait
à faire germer des idées
aujourd'hui les politiques sont très
très forts sur les réseaux sociaux parce
qu'ils ont conclu que c'était le
meilleur vecteur de communication et
donc j'avoue que ça soit à gauche comme
à droite
ils sont à fond sur les réseaux alors
c'est vrai qu'elle silbert à une cyber
harcèlement aussi on va parler de ce que
vous pouvez faire dans l'instant on
parle de cyber harcèlement mais par
exemple on dit aussi fonds peut acheter
de la drogue des armes sur internet en
deux clics c'est vraiment bien sûr ça
c'est bath et les dark knight market
marquent c'est les marchés du dark wave
en fait rare lesquels vous pouvez
justement avoir accès à drogue et armes
c'est les gens ils ont tendance à
fantasmer un peu là dessus mais c'est
juste télécharger tort et en trois clics
vous pouvez vraiment accéder à un marché
du dark knight a essayé de vous procurer
le moment bien sûr là l'exemple d'un
pistolet qu'on a pu retrouver en 2 3
ticks à coûte environ 590 euros en deux
trois clics voilà l'acquisition ou la
cession ou la détention de son
autorisation d'une arme et passible de 3
ans à celle d'emprisonnement et d'une
amende de 45000 euros
il ya aussi on peut on peut aussi
trouver des drogues dures sur internet
un lien sur tout les types de drogues en
fait c'est vraiment c'est celle amazones
du crime en fait c'est à dire que le
dark web c'est là où vraiment vous allez
pouvoir vous approvisionnez pour
absolument tout ce qui est illégal
alors juste robin des bois est ce que
vous pouvez rentrer dans le téléphone
d'une personne non infectée les fans de
chantier en
je m'attends mode avion bourgneuf n'en
arriverons à une cafétéria un téléphone
bien sûr on peut infecter un ordinateur
comme en finale en ayant le numéro de la
personne tout un renforcement pas
forcément avec le numéro alors il ya
deux types d'infection soit les
infections physique donc quand vous avez
accès à la machine ou un téléphone après
désinfection en ligne donc par exemple
si je vous fais si je vous envoie un
lien par exemple sur lequel j'essaye de
fiche est de récupérer derrière vos
bonnes adresses emails et vos mots de
passe et que vous cliquez sur ce lien
vous êtes infecté donne qu'en fait il
faut avoir une conscience numérique de
façon à pouvoir réaliser qu internet bah
c'est pas tout rose et qu'il ya des gens
qui vous veulent du mal et que
données personnelles vous devez en tout
cas les protéger et faire attention à
comment
oui oui et jouer ça est ce que vous
vivez aujourd'hui de vos talents de
hackers à ce qu on vous paye pour les
actionner pour que c'est arrêter toutes
les activités qui sont illégales mais si
jamais vous avez besoin avec votre
copine et que vous avez un billet a
lâché et ça peut se faire mais en gros
je veux c'est la question aux témoins
mais tout ce qui est illégal j'ai arrêté
à dire vous avez gagné beaucoup d'argent
en le fondant vous avez fait pendant dix
ans ça va grâce à dieu je n'ai pas à me
plaindre je le gagnerai m'a dit je j'ai
un bon salaire c'est pas bien de
documents mais non je joue en sort
plutôt bien justement parce que la
numérisation de la société c'est réel
aujourd'hui on est conditionné à penser
qu'un smic ou de smic ou 3 smic c'est
beaucoup alors qu'en réalité avec
internet vous pouvez très bien être
votre propre maître financiers quand
vous pouvez avoir votre votre livre leur
sens que je vais savoir est ce que par
exemple voilà la lame of de jean michel
si elle vous appelle est ce que vous
pouvez rentrer dans le téléphone de jean
michel allé voir ses sms et photos etc
ou pas damas de jean-michel web ainsi
j'ai son numéro et que écoeuré après je
vais essayer de lui envoyer n'importe
quoi un sms et que la clique sur le lien
malheureusement oui je pourrais essayer
de l'affecter ah ouais ouais mais après
j'ai pas envie très bonne idée non plus
il a répondu oui sophy moi j'ai un ami
s'il fait ça en fait je dois le dire ça
plus honteux mais je les fais je suis
rentré dans il est à coeur et je suis
rentré dans le téléphone d'un de mes ex
un oui très facilement et en fait je
recevais toutes ces notifications an mal
an des jeux c'est à dire que j'avais
tous les mêmes on dire sur ce que vous
vous êtes en train de dire il ya
carrément d entreprise qui se spécialise
dans l'espionnage familial c'est à dire
vous allez voir que votre mari vous
trompe que votre enfant farid est d'un
gris et bien vous allez pouvoir un style
qui prend deux mille euros pour le faire
rentrer dans le téléphone sur une donnée
durée des plongées plein plein plein de
copines qui ont fait castaldi qui est
blanc
[Rires]
j'applaudis la période ya plein de gens
là surtout il y aura deux sont comme des
fous en question sa critique pas passive
répondent aujourd'hui reçu des relevés
bancaires par tapie met tout son
énervement caire avec nous mais nos vies
chiffré et le code et on a le relevé
bancaire
est-ce que ça aussi vous pouvez rentrer
dans notre compte bancaire alors prendre
de l'argent bas en gros si vous voulez
quand vous allez sur un site oui pour
vous répondre déjà c'est oui c'est à
dire vous allez sur un site internet
auquel vous faites une commande vous
mettez matthieu delormeau vous mettez
vos numéros de cartes bancaires si le
site se fait piratée le hacker après
dispose de vos informations dont tu peux
utiliser votre carte bancaire il peut
revendre vos informations il peut faire
absolument ski lancy ge achète sur
internet donc il ne faut jamais que
j'achète sur un terrain pas forcément il
faut pas non plus être ne jamais acheter
amazon par exemple c'est quelque chose
de relativement mais ça dépend du site
en fait ça dépend du marchand sa
dépouille
mais ça dépend ça veut rien dire pour
nos mouchoirs sais pas si je vais
t'emmener points comme frères pipe en
juin j'ai lu qu'il y avait des poupées y
revint des bois qui utilisé internet
pour manipuler l'opinion et les 30 pays
ça s'appelle l'armée du clavier est ce
que oui ou non on peut manipuler ce que
vous pouvez rentrer dans ma tête et me
forcer à voir telle ou telle forme de
pensée moi pas forcément mais j'ai été
il ya alors pour vous dire carrément il
ya eu il ya des ingérences au niveau des
élections présidentielles qui ont été
faites en france en 2010 est aussi sur
les primaires ah ouais exemple quand
j'ai été menacé par un conte qui est
donc un compte qui est piloté par une
agence de renseignement russes qui m'a
menacé de mort à cause des révélations
que j'ai fait dans mon livre en fête
mais pour autant bien sûr c'est à dire
qu'on va essayer de le galvaniser les
deux sphères vous avez une sphère qui va
être pro extrême droite et vous allez
avoir une action contraire qui va être
bien plus populaire est donc le but de
ces gens là c'est de piloter des comptes
twitter facebook et instagram et des
deux sphères de façon à pouvoir créer le
chaos parce que quand tu créé le chaos
après tu peut générer tout ce que tu
veux c'est pas une surprise si
aujourd'hui il ya une récupération
politique énorme sur la ferme il a ou
sur n'importe alors fermement orientée
sur justement rabbins des bois qui sont
ces gens qui menace de mort sur internet
est ce que ce sont des défauts compte
est ce que sont des vraies personnes
si vous avez deux types de profils vous
avez le profil de madame michu qui est
devant sa télé qui s'offusque et qui du
coup va menacer de mort et d'un autre
côté vous allez avoir des gens qui vont
tout faire et donc c'est faux bien sûr
tout ça
faux c'est tout faire pour essayer de
générer une réaction
mais mes globale de la société
c'est-à-dire me l'a peut-être qu'elle
s'est fait menacer par des gens jeunes
elle n'avait aucune intention de la tuer
mais tout ça pour engendrer une réaction
une réaction en fait comme un grossiste
en fait votre exagéré le truc
alors c'est vrai que je vous le dis nos
données personnelles sont en danger
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire raban des
bois pour mine de rien protéger nos
données est ce qu'il ya des solutions ou
bien est-ce qu'on peut tous être à quai
voilà est-ce qu'on peut avoir accès au
téléphone de castaldi de normaux il faut
une confiance numérique une confiance
numérique signifie yen par rapport à ces
ordinateurs à ses téléphones se réaliser
que il faut utiliser des mots de passe
sécurisés pas les mots de passe partout
les mêmes sur tous les sites parce que
si j'en trouve ans après c'est à dire
que j'ai accès à tous il faut utiliser
des choses par exemple si ruud je vous
conseille pas de mettre en mots de passe
lino 1 2 3 ou bien 42,3 pas de choses
qui se voit sous le nom de maison
exactement pas de chose en soi qu'ils
soient de la sphère publique votre date
de naissance le nom de vos enfants en
fait tout ça il faut éviter
moi c'est ma couille 36 c'est vrai quoi
c'est il faut ils peuvent ils peuvent
tenter alors oui allez y mais juste on a
tous des box chez nous par la fibre on a
internet
donc ça quelqu'un se connecte sur ça
chez nous car c'est plus compliqué parce
que la noë failli c'est un fournisseur
d'accès internet
le chiffrement le système de chiffrement
de vos box c'est quand même là c'est
solide c'est raide c'est relativement
dure en fait de hack in box internet en
théorie pourrait se mettre avec un scan
sera d'accord bien sûr en théorie ni
avec un accès physique chez vous si je
viens chez vous pour réparer quelque
chose oui bien sûr voilà oui alors une
question de huy alors lâchez vous pouvez
à quai l'exode elle est ce couac et les
be bop
oui le concerne au premier chef andré
une cyber attaque est régulièrement du
régime mais si c'est m6 tout le groupe
rtl m6 régulièrement delà des
indications de la direction qui dit si
vous voyez tel message suspect surtout
ne cliquez pas annoncé comment je sais
moi que ces suspects alors quoi
mais non mais souvent c'est vous avez
gagné à nos questions d'isabelle pour
nos téléspectateurs qui nous regardent
en direct juste rabat des bois c'est
quoi le truc dont il faut se méfier les
messages dont il faut se méfier ferment
quand vous fait gagner quelque chose
il n'y a pas qu'eux après oui parce que
vous avez cité le cas de rtl m6 donc
vous on va vous attaquez on va vous
faire passer quelqu'un va vous envoyer
un message en faisant passer pour
collègues à vous paraît sage que c'est
quelque chose de très ciblée c'est une
vraie cyber attaques sur un gros groupe
mais pour madame michu où le citoyen
lambda là où généralement il assure
avoir c'est on va les mettre à dos
n'hésitez pas à payer pour ça des
joueurs impayés étage et c'est
exactement plein de choses en fait moi
on me dit tu as gagné un truc je suis un
rapport avait souvent c'est vous avez
payé trop d'impôts vont vous rembourse
100 euros cliquez c'est souvent ça les
mecs sont tellement contents les impôts
me rendre 100 euros et maquis clics tous
moi je crois alors est-ce qu'on peut
acheter des choses sur internet sans
avoir peur de mettre ses codes tout ça a
été assez rapide
il s'agit pas de rentrer dans une
paranoïa des plus totale l'attaquant
sites comme amazon ebay tous assez
classique mais après il faut avoir une
certaine chez passé c'est du bon sens en
fait d'après dire que si vous voyez que
le site
il pue de la gueule il n'a pas l'air
correct ne m'étais pas vraiment
informations de sud à quoi faut pas les
foyers sur des sites rico du caucase et
aussi ne pas cliquer n'importe où en
fait généralement oui j'ai gravé un des
bons on commande souvent les réseaux
sociaux est ce que par exemple contre
ceux réussis sur 30 étaient également
des mois des moines à god
quand on commente les tts que les tétées
nous on peut les est ce que vous pouvez
ainsi baer hacker peut les bourses ou
fait artificiellement hacker dtt d'été
mais je peut propulser un sujet entité
away notamment les policiers qui font ça
et les rênes des polémiques ont fait
brosser pour générer leurs interactions
du clic de la visibilité de l'exposition
ils vont avoir une armée de community
manager ou deux personnes qui sont payés
pour ça de façon à pouvoir engendrer des
réactions sur les réseaux sociaux alors
monté tout crédit un autre truc qui se
passe maintenant je le vois ma chez les
médecins
moi j'ai donc pirates les données et ils
demandent des rançons ces hackers il ya
de plus en plus j'ai un pote voilà sa
performance au médical ils ont hacké
toutes les données des patients et ils
ont demandé une rançon pour pouvoir
débloquer
gaillac et que ce qu'on peut faire dans
ces cas là à là c'est très compliqué
parce que c'est un mensonge y ciel en
anglais sa vie un run somewhere c'est
quelque chose qui s'est développée
depuis l'année dernière
concrètement l'année dernière avec wana
cry c'était le nom du virus en question
d aller simple c'est un peu précis mais
il ya eu il ya eu il ya eu plus de je
crois 60 systèmes qui ont été infectés
d'accord de france et de leurs mises en
garde parce qu'il est très inquiet
qu'opera de son compte de petits non
mais c'est vrai évidemment je suis très
inquiet pour ses beats vous attaquez oui
pour s'éviter des groupes b voilà ce que
vous vous prévoyez une guerre sur
internet c'est une guerre à prévoir mais
on est déjà avoir une énorme
cyberattaques c'est vrai ça alors pour
la guerre je pense qu'on est en plein
dedans déjà c'est à dire que la
cyberguerre c'est une guerre où on
essaye de vous persuader de choses on
essaye de vous convaincre c'est une
guerre d'idées et après moi je pense
qu'il va y avoir un cyber en septembre
c'est à dire je pense qu'il va se passer
quelque chose malheureusement ça peut
être les traitements des eaux ça peut
être le nucléaire ça peut être
l'électricité par exemple en ukraine à
kiev
il ya deux ans il ya tout un quartier
qui a sauté en électricité à cause d'une
cyberattaque et c'était la russie donc
ça c'est chaud je pense qu'on arrive
dans quelque chose comme sa version web
et il nous fait bien lève-toi et codes
rabbins des bois confession d'un hacker
ça c'est très très fort merci
aucun rapport l'internet lui à 77
pourtant non à 23 concernés